a lifetime or dead time according to
Robert Greene there are two types of
time in our lives dead time where people
are passive and waiting and a live time
when people are learning and acting and
utilizing every second every moment of
failure every moment or situation that
we did not deliberately choose or
control presents this choice a lifetime
dead time which will it be Francis Scott
Key wrote the poem that became the
national anthem of the United States
while trapped on a ship during a
prisoner exchange in the war of 1812
Viktor Frankl refined his psychologist
of meaning and suffering during his
ordeal in three Nazi concentration camps
Walter Scott's first great poem was
written while recovering from being
kicked by a horse Walt Disney made his
decision to become a cartoonist while
laid up after stepping on a rusty nail
yes it would feel much better in the
moment to be angry to be agreed to be
depressed or heartbroken when injustice
ouran fairness or the capriciousness of
faith are inflicted on someone the
normal reaction is to yell to fight back
to resist but what if we said this is an
opportunity for me i am using it for my
purposes i will not let this be dead
time for me the dead time was when we
were controlled by ego now now we can
live who knows what you're currently
doing hopefully it's not a prison term
even if it might feel like it maybe
you're sitting in a remedial high school
class maybe you're on hold maybe it's a
trial separation maybe you're making
smoothies as you save up money maybe
you're stuck waiting out a contract or
two of duty maybe the situation is one
totally of your own making or perhaps
it's just bad luck in life we all get
stuck with some dead time it isn't in
our control except that it is as booker
t washington most shamelessly put it
cast down your bucket where you are make
use of what you face don't let
stubbornness and ignorance make a bad
situation worse don't waste this no
matter how appeal
it happens to be you don't get very much
time a lifetime or dead time